How do you actually become a Christian?
In the video I want to show you quite practically,
how ne conversion can look.
is important to know beforehand,
that being a Christian is based on a personal decision,
to follow Jesus Christ is based.
You are not a Christian because you were as a baby,
because we live in a Christian country
or because the parents were Christians.
We understand per se Christian
not yet as a religious affiliation,
but a relationship with Jesus Christ.
The Bible says in the Roman 10 verse 9,
who confesses with his mouth,
that Jesus is the Lord and believes from the heart,
that God raised him from the dead,
that will be saved.
To be a Christian then,
it is best for you to go to prayer
and confess to my prayer,
Lord Jesus,
I believe in it,
that you are the Lord and I believe from the bottom of my heart,
that God has awakened you from the dead for me.
Give Me your holy spirit,
this is what it could look like.
They are not magic words,
that make you the Christian,
but it is 1 believe,
who made you become a Christian.
You're really just making it clear with words.
After praying the prayer,
you are a Christian,
get a Bible and find a good community.
Let's go!